that's not a kid that's a 13 year old
actor while harry and ron were bonding
on the hogwarts express
daniel and rupert weren't even filming
in the same compartment
looking back the harry potter cast has a
lot of revelations about what really
went down behind the scenes from the
props that actually terrified them
to lines you never knew were improvised
here's how the cast reacted to their
favorite
and least favorite moments on set paper
on bone
so i couldn't use that one emma watson
doesn't quite know her own strength
while daniel was re-watching the library
scene where emma hits him over the head
he revealed that she went a little
overboard there was one take
when it was very hard while the sound
was perfectly realistic they couldn't
use the take because both emma and
daniel cracked up afterwards
you're laughing because you hit me so
hard okay
the cast also enjoys looking back on
scenes they weren't in
particularly if that scene involves one
of their friends being hit in the head
repeatedly with projectiles can't wait
to see this
matthew lewis and alfie enoch reacted to
the training rupert had to do to
practice for his quidditch scene
it involved warming up with the stuntman
and then having a ball thrown at his
face to try and practice how he would
block
shots while flying on a broom oh god
that's got him in the face but don't
worry they made sure to hype him up a
little too
is there anything this man can't do i
don't think so did you know that during
the first film one of emma's teeth was
fake
how embarrassing is that she had just
lost one on her front teeth right before
filming
and i had to wear a kind of like a piece
like a tooth yeah but emma shouldn't be
too embarrassed the young cast later
revealed that they all had fake versions
of their teeth made
in case any of them lost some while
filming so they just like
cost everyone's mouth so it was bound to
happen to someone
teach test okay the very first scene
filmed in the entire series was of the
students leaving hogwarts and
nerves were running high daniel admits
he was feeling a lot like harry must
have been
it was slightly nerve-wracking i was
terrified emma felt the same way as it
was her first
time on such a big movie set never
stepped on a film set in my life
never acted professionally before and
then you walk onto this enormous set
and it was a lot more difficult than she
thought it would be it's not easy
rupert felt like he had some big shoes
to fill it was quite a scary
world to come into but he ended up
enjoying his first real acting
experience
i was really nervous but it turned out
was
quite cool one problem that comes with
filming a young cast is all the laughing
smiling and
general hijinks rupert in particular had
to be told a few times to relax his face
and be more serious
it didn't really work to be honest the
giggling got so bad that rupert
remembers how he and daniel couldn't be
in the same compartment on the hogwarts
express
they had to be separated to film all
their close-ups and lines
because we just couldn't look each other
in the eye and keep a straight face
looking back on all the eating he did in
the first few films rubert revealed that
all the wizarding world treats were
delicious and made specifically for the
movies this is before kind of you could
buy
all the kind of harry potter sweets they
even had a team of scientists working on
the every flavor beans which impressed
rupert
because it made his dreams of eating in
the harry potter universe a reality
he was one of the very first people to
get to try foods that are pretty famous
today this was all kind of coming
straight off the page
it was easy for rupert grint to pretend
to be afraid of aragog because in real
life he was
terrified it really didn't make me feel
uneasy i didn't didn't really like
looking at it at all there was no cgi
here just a huge mechanical spider that
could actually move
rupert was so disturbed by the animatron
creature that looking back he says he's
still not able to watch that scene
i just thought i just couldn't walk
still can't watch that scene
it's absolutely terrifying did you know
that lucious and harry's showdown at the
end of chamber of secrets was partially
improvised and there was no line there
and i said chris columbus
i just feel like he'd say something
jason isaacs went with let's hope mr
button will always be around to save the
day
but what shocked him was that daniel
effortlessly came up with a comeback
don't worry i will be isaacs was
entirely impressed by his skills
that's not a kid that's a 13 year old
actor thinking back
matthew lewis and alfie enoch can't help
but feel bad for the crew who had to try
and keep 11 year olds in line while they
were having fun with broomsticks
we were messing around all the time
while it was a bit scary
being strapped to a broom is one of
matthew's funnest memories from the
series
and they call it work it was it was
brilliant he even compared the
experience to an exhilarating ride at a
theme park
you're flying around on this roller
coaster type thing
reminiscing on one of his favorite
scenes rupert revealed that the
wizarding chess game from the very first
movie was pretty dangerous and involved
pyrotechnics the board was lit up with
real fire and when the pieces were hit
they actually exploded rupert even got
to keep a memento from this scene a
broken piece from the exploding horse
and he was praised by director chris
columbus for his performance rupert was
so
strong some harry potter sets were
completely digital
like the hall of prophecies but while
reacting to these scenes the cast admits
it was hard to give convincing
performances is this all we have
one of the ways they got around this was
by playing spooky sounds to get the
actors into the right mindset
but they still had to face the problem
of not having anything concrete to look
at
really be able to pinpoint where
everything is meant to be at the right
time
there were even markers and crew
standing off to the side to help show
the actors where to look
and in the end director david yates was
thoroughly impressed by the young cast
the greatest green screen pros in the
universe
the great hall was one of the most
massive sets in the entire series
but it was surprisingly 100 real it was
a huge room made of stone and even the
lit candles hanging from the ceiling
were real
emma revealed watching it back that she
didn't even have to pretend to be in
awe while filming no acting required it
also turns out that the cast's first
scene in the hall
was a surprise for everyone we've never
seen the great hall ever
even looking back they can't believe how
much this epic set
really brought hogwarts to life hermione
and ron's kiss seemed pretty romantic to
us but in reality emma and rupert think
back on that scene as one of the
weirdest and most
awkward ones to film kissing rupert uh
also awkward rupert felt weird about
kissing his friend of over ten years
just felt a little bit it felt quite
self-conscious while emma compared the
scene to kissing a sibling
it was honestly like kissing my brother
thankfully they wrapped it up in four
takes so that it was over pretty
quickly but it's a wonder they managed
to get a good take at all since they
couldn't stop laughing while the cameras
were rolling
fiona shaw will never forget a problem
she had while dealing with some of the
first film's animal actors
the owls were supposed to look at aunt
petunia during the scene but they kept
getting distracted by the camera so the
crew had to come up with a solution that
wasn't very appealing
we hung dead mice from my apron it
definitely made the owls focus on her
more but we'll never look at this scene
the same
now that we know about aunt petunia's
interesting fashion accessory
warwick davis pulled double duty in the
first film as the gringotts bank teller
and professor flitwick i was made look
very different as the bank teller
but despite amazing prosthetics that
made him look creepy he remembers
getting giggles out of daniel during
their scene
chris wanted dan to kind of look shocked
however davis's attempt to make daniel
look even remotely phased
didn't work at all
but in the end daniel managed to at
least look confused while being
surrounded by actors covered in thick
layers of prosthetics
and does mr harry potter have his key
while rupert grint's happy to react to
onset moments
you might be surprised to know that he's
never seen the entire series he's only
watched the first three films
though he does say he's open to changing
that now that he started a family
we wonder which one will end up being
his favorite